it is May 2nd 2023 and you're watching
the code report if you haven't deployed
an app to production at 4 59 pm on
Friday that accidentally deletes a
production database causing your entire
team to work all weekend while the
company loses a billion dollars on its
market cap while you go fishing and get
fired on Monday you haven't really lived
developers are terrified of screwing
things up when deploying apps which is
why platforms like for sale netlify
Heroku and Firebase are incredibly
popular when your boss says all you
gotta do is not up the obvious
solution is to use a platform to handle
deployment for you versel is the
platform of choice for next JS
deployments but the one big thing it's
missing is a database well not anymore
just yesterday Purcell announced not one
not two not three but four new databases
everybody in Tech wants to sell you a
fully managed database it's a huge
multi-billion dollar industry with tons
of competition in the startup ecosystem
and rightfully so because managing a
database is extremely difficult and if
you screw things up it's game over let's
see what Purcell has to offer in my
opinion the most exciting new option is
for cell postgres serverless SQL for the
front end Cloud which is an SQL database
powered by neon neon is an awesome
product and coincidentally I used it
when building my new next js13 course
which is now available to fireship Pro
members if you want to learn all about
it what's nice about this database is
that it scales automatically it's fault
tolerant and has a nice UI that's just
easy to work with basically all you do
is click a button add your database
connection link to the environment and
then you can start writing raw SQL code
directly in a server component with
next.js it also integrates nicely with
libraries like keisely and my personal
favorite Prisma while neon is definitely
awesome as a building block it's still
quite a ways behind tools like super
bass that have a really Advanced UI
where you can do row level security
procedures and a bunch of other stuff
we've also done a full course on Super
Bass but I don't think Russell is going
for that full back end as a service
approach I think they want to be more of
a front-end Cloud that provides you with
a bunch of different infrastructure
options one funny side note for next JS
users is that in the blog post it looks
like they leaked the details for a new
API called server actions apparently
that'll be announced Thursday but
basically it looks like you can create
server functions alongside your
components to handle form submissions
without needing to create API routes
this is an awesome feature and I'm glad
to see that next is finally stealing it
from remix but now let's check out
database number two versil KV a key
Value Store like redis based on upstash
e-value databases are extremely easy to
use but more importantly they're
extremely fast because unlike most
databases the data is held in memory
instead of on the disk well it is stored
on disk as well but because it's also in
memory you get extremely fast reads
making it ideal as a cache for your data
database number three is Edge config
which allows you to distribute
configuration variables across the edge
Network providing virtually instant
reads for things like feature Flags if
you do a b testing or if you have a list
of malicious IPS you could store them on
the edge and then use nexjs middleware
to block those requests and finally that
brings us to database number four versus
blob it's based on cloudflare R2 which
allows you to store large amounts of
unstructured data like images and PDF
files on the edge in other words it's a
replacement for storage buckets like S3
and that could be a game changer if your
app does file uploads the SDK is
incredibly simple all you do is a way to
call to put with the file that you want
to upload and it returns you with a
download URL that's pretty awesome but
one limitation currently is that the max
file upload size is four megabytes
however that should increase after the
beta phase versus gets a lot of
attention but what you might have missed
is that Dino also just released its own
Global key value database it's based on
foundationdb which is developed by Apple
and is extremely fast while also
supporting consistency and acid
transactions and the API is incredibly
easy to use with zero setup choosing a
database in 2023 is harder than ever if
you thought the JavaScript framework war
was bad it's nothing compared to the
database War where companies have
billions of dollars at stake all
competing to store your data this has
been the code report thanks for watching
and I will see you in the next one
[Music]